i watched
more anime
i did too actually what did you watch i
watched attack on time oh me too me too
what is going on now
joey's watched as joey's only and first
animation
he can't just drop this bombshell on me
guys i
i tweeted about how uh the first two
episodes were wild and then i
immediately uh silenced yeah yeah you
got a friend you got it yeah i muted it
yeah i didn't see it at all but i
guarantee all the comments were like you
don't watch
by the time this anime comes out i think
episode six
sounding like that yeah it's like 12
episodes of the season oh really yeah
yeah
i had to almost i had to go back a
couple of episodes just because it
really does just like throw you in well
i mean it is uh just a continuation
right right
i think i've completely forgotten about
that i was like oh it's just the new
season right so i was like i was waiting
for like the recap
and i was like where is it
where is it what's happening because
like now anime has this thing where they
call things seasons but they're really
not [ __ ] seasons like it's it's just
parts right it's final season part two
yeah right
there part two of season three yeah that
was a part two of season three so season
three part one season three part two and
then final season part one final season
part two because cause like the last
season wasn't really a season because it
was just a story arc that was cut right
in the middle of the story right so i
wouldn't really call that like a full
season you know so this was just like
the continuation of the attack on time
and i completely forgot about that when
i started the first episode of part two
yeah so we just [ __ ] say that
final season yeah when i started episode
one final season part two final season
the actual finals yeah the actual final
season supposedly but uh yeah it's deja
looks pretty good this season huh
cgi looks pretty good this year
it doesn't look that bad actually the
tides have gotten a lot better yeah cgi
i don't know
i haven't actually watched the new uh
attack on titan season i don't know if
i'm just being like i'm i'm just used to
it but yeah i think the cgi titans look
a lot better than they did in the
previous season
i didn't really notice that until i saw
on twitter that people were complaining
about i was like oh well you know they
complain about anything yeah exactly
exactly they feel like detectives i'm
sorry i found the cgi guys i did it yeah
right i saw it if i cross reference the
manga panel that they took this from
like i saw a guy on twitter like
complaining about the cgi and part six
jojo as well like the other day where he
was literally like i i don't know who it
was but i saw an image where it was like
side beside comparison
like arrows of just like this is part
five and this is how many cgi things are
in the background and this is part six
and this is how many cgi things there
are in the background
i'm just like we are getting to like the
[ __ ] always sunny charlie meme at
this point you know like you know it
like i i i can't comment on the attack
on titan final season cgi but it wasn't
too bad why do people part one people
just hate cgi they just like the the 2d
art style i get it you know obviously i
would prefer 2d yeah i don't i wouldn't
lose any sleep over cgi being included
i'm not yeah
i don't really care i mean does it does
it affects the story
or the impact of the story
i get more annoyed when they just don't
even animate stuff like i think there
was a fight in the in the previous part
one of final season that i wish they'd
animated
there's a fight in it that i wish that
they'd actually done something with but
they just kind of didn't show anything
okay they kind of like cut to the
aftermath of it yeah that's when i'm
like well that's [ __ ] i'm like show me
something even if it's cgi i'd love to
have something to do with levi yeah yeah
okay okay i know i know the moment yeah
yeah yeah that one that one was kind of
disappointing yeah that was another one
really disappointing show anything
that's where i'm like okay now this is
[ __ ] when they're not even showing the
fight yeah yeah that's what it bothers
me the only thing i would say that i
think has been a step down is that the
story of attack on titan final season
has been amazing but
um compared to like what previous
seasons did that wasn't like that epic
oh my god fight moments yeah um and i
feel like that's the only thing that's
really missing from this final season or
that has been missing because like there
are some amazing action moments in the
previous seasons and this one has just
been amazing for the story yeah the
conflict yeah i you i look forward less
and less for the action scenes and more
so what's gonna happen whereas you know
like
season three part one i had that
glorious uh scene which you've probably
seen all over because the gifts are like
yeah
that's [ __ ] like anything involving levi
is just like that
it was kind of interesting when that
came out you know everyone was like
joking that attack on titan season two
was so boring yeah and then that that
scene came out in part in season three
yeah right
part one and everyone was just like
attacking tight hype again everyone was
like that one scene made everyone hyped
for attack on titan yeah it was so well
done it was insane yeah i mean i mean
there were even like some scenes in
season two though like [ __ ]
incredible as well people just didn't
care cause it took five years right or
like four years yeah it took like yeah
five
five six it also
it was also the point it was also the
point where the story started to get
like had like the political side of it
all like in the story in the world it
wasn't too slow so it was a lot harder
for people to get like hyped over there
they weren't gonna be like yo politics
hype you know they weren't gonna but i
think that's just because it was like so
different from season one because season
one was just like it was so fast-paced
and so action-packed that people like it
was so cut and dry and like straight to
the point yeah like this is what's
happening you're gonna get hyped for
this fight this fight this fight yeah
yeah yeah and i i'm glad they slowed it
down in season two and literally like
built up the characters built up this
world because that now i think it's so
much better for it it's it's like a much
like the pale show for like the action
scenes now has just become like so much
greater yeah even though part the final
season part two right now there isn't
really any like fight scene that's made
me go i mean i've only seen the first
two episodes but like there hasn't been
a fight scene that's made me go like
everything's a fight right now
if anything the one thing that's been
talked about is that [ __ ] face right
oh my god yeah that's been like mean i
don't i don't even know the context of
that
i've seen it like on my timeline yeah
this caught me off guard that caught me
off guard as well yeah i was like whoa
it's like a horror anime now what the
[ __ ] i guess i guess it'll be
interesting to see how our opinions
change when it's over and yeah our final
thoughts on it yeah interesting i would
be interested in following it now for
like i don't know six
do you think do you feel like this is
the anime that has like just define this
modern generation of anime fans yeah
yeah this is going to be the show for
the next 10 years that when someone was
like i want to watch anime what do i
watch
go back on the greats of the 2000's and
it's like well attacked obviously
yeah because it is it is like as much
people want to be like no it's [ __ ]
whatever because they want to have like
a counter opinion like no it is it is
like this it's a great show generation
i'm interested to see how the ending is
gonna go down
um because whether it is good or not
because i i don't know because i'm not a
margarita whether it's good or not um
the anime community is probably going to
explode one way or the other yeah
right through through discussion i still
don't i don't know how i've like [ __ ]
dodged all these spoilers i don't know
anything
yeah because whenever you even like
utter the word attack on titan ending
all the [ __ ] mongeri just come out of
the shadows like war veterans being like
ah
one of those
it's divisive yeah it's good that means
it's going to be interesting yeah i'm
excited because if it was if everyone
agreed like it's decent i'd be like [ __ ]
now that i know it's divisive i know
that i'm i'm in for something good yeah
i'm like i'm like
i'm like preparing a nuclear shelter for
a [ __ ] twitter that's when the ending
comes out i know that twitter is going
to be like a [ __ ] landmine oh yeah
definitely
i'm hyped for it i'm hyped any opinion
will be shattered
by the opposite party it's going to be
one of those shows where
you you just need to watch it just so
you can have a take on it you know yeah
like your personality is going to be
defined on whether you on what take you
have on the attackers
so my credentials for a boyfriend over
six feet uh i thought the ending of
attack on titan was good uh if you don't
fit please get out that's how you know
man it'll be interesting i'm really
really hyped and also it's probably the
longest anime that i've been following
where it's like okay it's finally like
an end is in sight yeah and like an
actual ending not a oh they [ __ ] up
the production oh it's gone now it's
never going to yeah yeah it's like an
actual wrap-up of a long-running game
yeah it's i can't even remember the last
time i experienced something like this
where i was just watching an anime and
it was like it just ended and it's i had
to wait years for it to end actually i
know it's even getting on but
aside from that i just realized it it's
just all covered it's just all come
recently
i wasn't there for the stuff that's what
i'm saying like for me it's like because
i've been there from like the beginning
like you've lived through the initial
every single phase of attack on titan
hype and controversy and everything yeah
i've been through it all so having it
come to an end is gonna feel so weird
because even like if you're like all
right well one piece it's like yeah but
one piece is around before you were
around right kind of while i watched it
started in 96 money right well you
weren't reading one
right like imagine if you're like a 50
year old japanese salary man who's been
reading one piece into your 20s it must
be like really weird to think that one
day it's going to end yeah yeah unless
you've been around forever and conscious
around every single phase of it well
that's that's what a bunch of 50 year
old salary men were like when naruto
ended right yeah true well like you know
like bleach right it's like it's like oh
my god crazy [ __ ] over i don't know
like to me naruto the narrator only got
like soured by the fact that boruto i
think was like announced right even like
before it ended so i'm just like well
it's an ending i'm i'm emotional but i
know it's not really ending and because
there's more of it yeah because there's
already more of them yeah you know
that's true i wish i could go back and
watch death note like what episode one
through like 30 seconds just log on to
twitch i know i i i shouldn't sorry
oh
could you imagine if you were around
when death note was uh if it was an
anime only and it was like week by week
holy [ __ ] that would have been crazy i
wish i was there
i mean i was i was there during the
second half of when the manga was
serializing yeah and even that was
[ __ ] crazy yeah and like and even
because like i it obviously started
before i started reading showing a job
right so i had to like do a quick catch
up to like keep up with everyone and
even then that was [ __ ] crazy should
only imagine the levels of hype that it
would reach nowadays something like that
dropped today yeah it was it was weird
because i i was one of the guys who was
watching like death note when it aired
and it was just a different vibe because
rather than people discussing it weekly
you just you just had people be like
watch death note it's amazing so you'd
only get like discussions of the entire
show after it finished as opposed to yo
did you catch the newest episode [ __ ]
yeah
i let it go removed from the alphabet
well that was [ __ ] insane man
it's true though i wish i wish i could
have been around with something like
that i don't even know like it's so i
guess i don't know what the next show is
that's going to be like that one i don't
know maybe mushoka tensei i don't know
maybe i hope so i mean it's it's it's a
hard shoe to fill but just because it's
we you very rarely see anime that
literally appeals to everyone and has
everything that everyone likes yeah
everything i i do hope the next one is
mishka tensei because they literally
created a studio just to make this one
show
but they kind of need to because of how
long the story is it follows like his
entire life
how many episodes do you think you'll
probably need like six seasons
sixties that's yeah because many
compared to like one piece or something
that's true that's true but like in
terms of that many
high quality episodes that's that's like
yeah
and it feels like more like an
autobiography or like a biography of a
fictional character